el papá de jaime le dio un dado por su
cumpleaños quería asegurarse de que no
estuviera tocado así que lo llevo a la
escuela lo tiro 500 veces y registro el
número de veces en el que el dado dio
cada número
después calculó el valor esperado de la
suma de 20 tiros obteniendo un valor de
67.4 el valor esperado de la suma de 20
tiros obteniendo un valor de 67.4 en su
camino a la escuela estaba lloviendo y
dos valores se borraron de su tabla de
datos encuentra las dos frecuencias
absolutas faltantes de la tabla de datos
de jaime
vemos aquí que tiró el dado 500 veces y
escribió cuántas veces obtuvo 12 obtuvo
12 110 veces 13 95 veces un 470 veces un
5 75 veces y también escribió cuántas
veces obtuvo un 1 y un 6 pero se
borraron por lo que tenemos que
descifrar cuántas veces obtuvo 1 y 6
basándonos en la información de esta
tabla de aquí y también en que el valor
esperado de la suma de 20 tiros es 67.4
y te invito a pausar el vídeo e intentar
resolverlo por tu cuenta antes de que
empiece a trabajar con él
bueno primero hay que pensar en que nos
está diciendo este valor esperado que
significa que la suma de 20 tiros sea
67.4
eso significa que el valor esperado de
un tiro el valor esperado de la suma de
20 tiros es sólo 20 por el valor
esperado de un tiro así que el valor
esperado de un tiro y déjenme escribirlo
por aquí el valor
esperado
d
un tiro
va a ser igual
punto 4 dividido entre 20
y podemos sacar nuestra calculadora
veamos
tenemos 60 y 7.4 dividido entre
dividido entre 20 es
ese punto
37 entonces esto es igual
punto
y como nos ayuda a eso bueno sabemos
cómo calcular un valor esperado dada
esta tabla de frecuencias de aquí si
decimos que este número de aquí este
a mayúsculas y digamos que este número
de acá es b
mayúscula si queremos calcular el valor
esperado de un tiro lo que realmente
queremos hacer es tomar la frecuencia
ponderada de cada uno de estos valores
la suma ponderada por ejemplo si tenemos
un 1
a de 500 veces va a ser
sobre
quinientas veces por uno
por uno más
más haré esto en colores diferentes más
110 de 500 veces por 2 más 110 de 500
veces por 2 y no está está es la
frecuencia en la que tienen dos por dos
estamos tomando una suma ponderada de
estos valores
y luego es más 95 de 500 por 3 más 95 de
más y creo que puedes ver a dónde está
yendo esto 70 sobre 500 por 4 más 70
sobre 500
por 4
y casi acabamos más veamos no he
utilizado este color más 75
sobre 500 por y continuaré por acá
+ 75 sobre
500 x 5 y finalmente más más b sobre 500
+ d
sobre
500 x
esto nos va a dar nuestro valor esperado
de un tiro lo que va a ser igual a 3.37
así que todo esto todo
es igual am es igual a 3.3 puntos 37
una cosa que podemos hacer ya que
tenemos estos 500 como denominadores
multipliquemos a ambos lados de la
ecuación por 500 si hacemos eso el lado
izquierdo de la ecuación se convierte en
bueno 500 x sobre 500 sólo sera
a más
110 o más bien 110 por 2 será 220
más 95 por 3 qué será
15 - que 300 así que será 285 más 285 y
luego 70 por 4 es 280 más 280 75 por 5
va a ser 350 por 25 375 así que es más
375 más 6 b 6 b espero que no me esté
saltando ningún paso aquí más
va a ser igual a va a ser igual a esto
por 500 y eso va a ser igual a 3.37
x
500 es igual a mil 685 mil 685 así que
todo lo que hice para ir de este paso de
aquí y empecé diciendo que este es el
valor esperado de una tirada que ya
sabemos que es 3.37 fue solo multiplicar
ambos lados de esta ecuación por 500
solo multiplique esto por 500 y
multiplique esto y multiplique esto por
500 y este 500 obviamente cancela todo
esto y luego 500 x 3.37 es 1685 y es lo
que tengo aquí
ahora tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 sólo quería
confirmar que tuviera el número correcto
de términos para no cometer errores
ahora sí vamos a simplificar esto
podemos restar 220 285 280 y 375 de
ambos lados entonces si hiciéramos eso
obtendríamos
si restamos esto del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación tendríamos a
más césped
+ 6
y en el lado derecho de la ecuación
vamos a obtener saquemos nuestra
calculadora
1685 menos menos 220 220 menos 285 menos
285 menos 280 menos 280 menos 375 menos
375 nos da 525 obtenemos
más
ven
es igual a
520 5 y dirás está bien decimos todo
este trabajo pero todavía tenemos una
ecuación con dos incógnitas cómo podemos
saber lo que hay ve cómo podemos saber
lo que hay ve son realmente
bueno y sabemos algo más y de hecho esto
es más fácil de encontrar
sabemos que la suma de toda esta tabla a
110 más 95 más 70 75 más b es igual a
500 o sí y déjame anotar eso así que
sabemos sabemos qué
+ + 110
más
más 75
más ve más ve tiene que ser igual a 500
necesita ser igual
vientos o podemos restar 110 95 más 70
75 de ambos lados y obtener si los
restos del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
sólo te quedas con a más b
+ b y en el lado derecho de la ecuación
si empezamos con si empezamos con 500
entonces son 500
menos 110 menos menos 95
- 70
- 75 nos lleva a 150 por lo que a más b
es igual a 150 es igual a 150 y ahora
tenemos un sistema de dos ecuaciones y
dos incógnitas y sabemos cómo se
resuelven esos o podemos hacerlo por
sustitución o podemos sustraer la
segunda ecuación de la primera así que
hagamos eso restamos el lado izquierdo
de la ecuación de eso
es inicialmente podemos sumar o podemos
multiplicar esta por uno menos uno
y luego sumar estas dos ecuaciones las a
se cancelan y nos queda 6 b
d
es igual a 375 es igual a 375 lo hice
bien si sumo 125 a esto obtengo 500 y
con otros 25 obtengo 525 por lo que 5b
es igual a 375 o si dividimos ambos
lados entre 5 obtenemos
d
igual a
ve es igual a 75 v es igual
75 por lo que esto de aquí es igual a 75
si ve es igual a 75 cuanto está bueno
sabemos que a más b es igual a 500
resolvimos eso antes de multiplicar
ambos lados de la ecuación por menos 1 y
sabemos que a
más bien además ve donde ahora ve 75 así
que podemos decir
mart 75
es igual
es igual a 150 es igual a 150 de esto
sacamos que a más b es igual a 150 antes
de que multiplicaremos ambos lados por
un negativo resta 75 de ambos lados y
obtienes
es igual a 75 y terminamos